hey it's evan i believe it's important
to thank the people who make a
difference in your life thank them in
person thank them publicly let them know
that that you're grateful for the work
that they've they've given you for the
support that they've given you
and so today i'd like to thank jason
jason joined my team a few months ago
and has been helping me with
a lot of the stuff that the brand
revitalization at my business coming up
with uh new logos and designs and
concepts and every important business
decision i usually run through him as
well to get a sounding board
i met jason uh through my forums now
jason was a really active contributor in
my forums and was just really positive
was was helping people thanking people
was was a force for good
in my forums
and uh i thought you know at some point
i got to get to know this guy and
we met at an event
there was um an entrepreneur friend of
mine who runs a coffee shop and a bus
ran through her front door
you know
a bus
as if it's not hard enough to run a
business you have to worry about a bus
kind of smashing through your front door
apparently it was trying to swerve away
from a cyclist and it you know missed
the cyclist thankfully but ran right
into my friend's coffee shop front door
so i thought i got to do something to
help and she was closed for weeks from
the repairs and when she opened up again
i thought i'm going to surprise her and
what i did was i i wanted to create a
special event where i'd invite people
that i knew to her coffee shop and just
overwhelm the store and flood the store
with customers who would go and meet and
hang out with me and also
you know buy some of her stuff so she
can make some money i thought it'd be a
nice surprise for her so i sent out a
list a newsletter to my list and said
hey guys
on this day this time come meet me at
little nicki's and we're gonna surprise
the owner and have a good time and
support her here's what happened here's
our story
and jason came
and that was the first time i actually
met jason in person and the surprise was
kind of in my city
and after all of our
online back and forth
and i met him and we had a great talk
and from there
uh you know we kept in touch online but
hadn't done anything
and i had one night free i had a
thursday night free and i thought you
know what jason he's been so so good on
my forms and he came and helped support
uh little nicki's i want him i want to
get to know him a little bit more
and so i wrote him and said jason what
are you doing this thursday let's meet
up and have a coffee and talk about you
know business and see what you're up to
and uh it was great i thought maybe i'd
meet him for an hour hour and a half
whatever i think that first meeting was
four or five hours and and we closed
down the coffee shop and had great
conversations
uh and that led to a couple other
meetings a couple little projects and we
found that we worked really well
together and he was all about the big
picture and believes in entrepreneurs
and uh and we found a way to work
together and since then he's been on
board and it's just been a big
shot of adrenaline and motivation for
the company and helping the whole team
and coming up with new concepts and
ideas to move the business forward and
not only come with ideas but actually
executing and
grinding it out and coming back to the
office at you know 11 o'clock at night
to keep pounding out ideas
and uh so jason very grateful thank you
so much for all your support and
creativity and wisdom and i'm looking
forward to uh
many great things
and so for everybody watching
you know for the people who have
supported you and your business and
there's tons right you can't do this
alone there are people who are helping
you along the way the people who have
given you support ideas money advice
encouragement thank those people let
them know that you appreciate it
and that
that they mean something to you and if
it's a video like this that you're
making or a quick email that you're
gonna send their handwritten note or
whatever it is it doesn't have to cost
anything you have to go buy them an
expensive gift basket just let them know
that you appreciate all the work and all
the help that they've given you and that
you couldn't have done it without them
believe
for those of you guys watching you liked
the video
give it a thumbs up below let me know
let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath your comments make me
keep going i love seeing them come in so
thank you guys and i'll see you on the
next episode